c'est à l'espace ce n'est que la
municipalité de triel sur seine a remis
de nombreux cadeaux à l'association les
enfants de la terre lundi 18 janvier une
collecte qui a été fait en décembre par
les habitants eux-mêmes avec le soutien
du collectif triel solidarité les landes
soya d'arrêter a duré trois semaines
c'est à dire tous les week-ends il y
avait une des collègues qui étaient
régulières sur la ville on allait aussi
bien aux châtelaine qu'en bord de seine
et avec cette collecte
il ya eu déjà une salle complète donc ça
va vers présente on va dire 80 mètres
carrés qui était entièrement plein de
cadeaux donc vraiment c'était
impressionnant
ça a été déjà redistribué à plusieurs
associations caritatives dont les restos
du coeur secours catholique est
aujourd'hui donc c'est les enfants de la
terre basé à thiverval grignon et créé
il y à 33 ans par marc éclair perrier la
mère de yannick noah
l'association est aujourd'hui présidée
par sa soeur nathalie les enfants de la
terre vient en aide aux enfants en
difficultés sociales et économiques en
france ou encore en afrique
ça me fait chaud au coeur et vous cache
pas que c'est la première fois qu'on a
une collecte comme ça hein c'est très
rare en général les gens nous donnent
souvent des cdd des jouets d'occasion
ce qui est très bien mais là c'est voilà
je pense que c'est un vrai noël un vrai
noël qu'on va faire passer à plein de
petits enfants beaucoup dans les
hôpitaux beaucoup à l'hôpital debré
beaucoup dans les hôpitaux et je pense
qu'il ya deux trois cadeaux que j'ai
déjà vu j'en ai vélo qu'on pourra pas
mettre dans les hôpitaux donc là les
offrira dans les maisons tendresse qu'on
a ce petit village si la première fois
qu'on a une collecte aussi belle et
aussi au temps de jouer tout en
s'adaptant à la crise sanitaire
l'association démarrera les premières
distributions de cadeaux dans les
hôpitaux
samedi 23 janvier